This video is made possible by VIN sero, watches luxury,
hence crafted watches. At fair prices,
you can check them out at vinserrawatches.com forward slash biographics.
And right now they have the biggest sale in the history to celebrate this
economy. 30% off site-wide moral, unlimited bits
On the morning of January the 15th, 1947 Los Angeles resident,
Betty Bazinga was walking with a young daughter through Leimert park.
When she came upon an unexpected site in a vacant lots on South Northern Avenue,
there was what appeared to be a naked body,
completely split into two halves at the waist.
The scene was so shocking that Mrs Bazinga immediately dismissed it as simply
being a store mannequin that had been thrown away.
It wasn't until she got closer, that she made a gruesome realization.
She was looking at the very real body of a young woman who had been slain
drained of blood cut into and posed Mrs. Bazinga runaway in
Tara and alerted the authorities,
the eventual arrival of the police and the media triggered the start of one of
the most infamous criminal investigations in history.
One which still remains a dark mystery. The case of the black Dahlia.
[Inaudible].
It wasn't long before the grisly discovery attracted an audience to play witness
to a scene that made even hardened police officers shut up.
Besides the fact that the young woman's body had been cut in two between the
second and third lumbar vertebrae,
it had also suffered extensive mutilation to the face breasts and genitals that
appears to have been done.
Post-mortem there were also signs that the women had been tied up with ligature
restraints and sexually assaulted before a death.
The autopsy concluded that she had been killed about 10 hours prior to her
discovery and the official cause of death was hemorrhage and shock due to
concussion of the brain and lacerations of the face.
The killer was clearly very proud of his work and wanted to display it as best
as possible. There was not a single drop of blood at the scene,
not on the body and not on the ground.
The murderer took the time to clean the cops with gasoline and then pose it in a
degrading position with the hands above the head and the legs spread wide open
with the intestines gathered in a pile at the lower half of the body,
the victim was left just a few feet away from the sidewalk.
It was pretty obvious that the killer not only made no attempts to conceal his
gruesome deed, but actually wanted it to be.
[Inaudible].
It's vulnerable.
Do you prove to be quite easy for the Los Angeles police departments brought in
the FBI to help with the investigation and they already have the victim's
fingerprints on file just 56 minutes after sending the Prince to Washington
Vajra primitive fax machine called a sound photo,
the woman was identified as 22 year old Elizabeth Short,
who wants applied for a clerk job at the camp cook army commerce or in
California. They even had a mugshot of her as short,
had been arrested once for underage drinking.
Elizabeth Short was born on July the 20, 1924 in Boston, Massachusetts.
The third of five daughters of Cleo and Phoebe may short,
her childhood was also filled with tragedy.
Initially her father had been a moderately successful businessmen who built
miniature golf courses,
but then the stock market crashed in 1929 and he lost almost all of his savings.
The following year Cleo's car was found abandoned on the Charlestown bridge in
Boston.
And everyone concluded that he had committed suicide by jumping into the river
left alone with five children to raise Phoebe may have to sell the house and
move into a smaller apartment while working as a bookkeeper to support our
family, to add to our troubles.
Elizabeth was a sickly child who suffered from severe asthma attacks and
bronchitis and needed lung surgery when she was just 15 years old.
But Elizabeth story took an unexpected turn in 1942.
When the family received a letter from her presumed to be deceased father,
as it turned out, he did not kill himself,
but he did decide to leave his family and start a new life in California.
And now years later,
he finally had worked up the courage to tell them the truth and to apologize,
the idea of starting over in a new place, appealed to Elizabeth,
who had recently dropped out of high school,
but who was also told by her doctors that it would be better for her to spend
winters somewhere with a mile to climates, to alleviate a respiratory problems.
Therefore, when she turns 18,
she left Massachusetts and joins her father in VA who California,
this new relationship, however, did not last long.
Elizabeth and Cleo argued a lot. So now in 1943, she moved out.
Once she found a job at the AFA mentioned camp cook.
She bounced between places for a while. Before she relocated to Florida,
they actually met an army Apple's officer names, major Matthew Michael Gordon,
Jr. Unfortunately, their romance was cut short by world war two.
As the pilot was deployed to the Indian theater whilst recovering from injuries
sustained in the crash. Gordon wrote to shorts to propose marriage.
She accepted, but never got to CFA on say again,
Gordon died in another crash just a few weeks before the end of the war in 1946,
Elizabeth decided that she needed another change of scenery.
So she moved once again, this time to Los Angeles,
she worked as a waitress and lived in a one room apartment behind a nightclub.
It was alleged that she occasionally resulted to prostitution to make ends meet.
So although this was never proven,
it is also commonly asserted that she was hoping to make it big in Hollywood as
an actress, but she had no acting credits to our name.
I had a field day with this case as the entire country became enraptured with
the murder of Elizabeth Short, she was known as the black Dalio.
Although the origins of this famous Monica are a bit murky.
Some say that the newspapers came up with a nickname while others claimed it was
something that our friends called her or the staff at the restaurant where she
works. One journalist specified that the papers popularized the name,
but that the writers had heard it from police officers who originally learned it
from friends and colleagues of Elizabeth Short.
The reasoning behind the nickname is again, a bit iffy.
It referenced a movie that was popular at the time called the blue Dalio,
but changed the color due to Elizabeth Short's dark hair and a penchant for
wearing black lace dresses. It's pretty safe to that's.
If the media had not become so obsessed with this murder,
the case of the black Dahlia would probably not be well remembered today case in
point just a month later, another gruesome killing took place in Los Angeles,
dubbed the lipstick murder this time that naked and severely beaten body of a 44
year old woman named John French was found inside a West LA apartments.
The killer seemingly wrote the words,
you BD on the victims torso with red lipstick and even scientists work
with the name of tax,
the Los Angeles Harold's express rent with the headline where Wolf strikes
again, kills LA women rights BD on body. They concluded that BD,
you could only stand for back daily and that the same killer was responsible for
both crimes. As it turns out, the message actually said PD, which was short,
most likely for police departments,
but it was indicative of how the newspapers were desperate to milk the story of
the black Dahlia. Everything was worth without a doubt.
The most egregious and exploitative example of journalism came courtesy of the
Los Angeles examiner,
who stooped to new lows to get the scoop on Elizabeth Short's early years.
Soon after red Baldy was identified reporters from the examiner called up her
mother before she learns that her daughter had been murdered. Instead,
they told her that Elizabeth had won a beauty contest and we're looking for
background info on her life only afterwards.
Did Mrs. Short find out the horrible truth about what had really happened now,
just before we get into the investigation, let's take a quick break.
So I can tell you about today's sponsor VIN, Sarah watches,
VIN sero creates exceptionally crafted timepieces of fair prices.
They're great looking certainly not minimalists like a lot of watches available
on the market today. No,
they have a bold rather than just sort of blending in
and looking like every other watch out there, right.
Is watch the people will notice. It's a wash that people compliment you on.
Now I've got a couple of them, the one I'm wearing I've actually,
I've got three of them. Don't want I'm wearing them.
The risk right now is the Krono asks. This is a very classic looking watch.
I've got the, uh, silver and blue combination.
A couple of other things I've got is the, uh, the rogue,
which is more of a sports watch style. It's got the rubber strap, it's got the,
uh, folding class like this, and it's a great looking V slightly larger.
So it's a bit larger on the wrist. So if you're a larger wristed gentlemen,
this is perfect for you. I have small watch smaller wrists.
So I tend to smaller watches. There's also this one, this is fantastic.
This is the pilot. Watch their take on a pilot. Watch.
This is called the altitude and it's great.
It's got the red second time ticking behind that. Also a dual time zone,
which is fantastic. If you travel a lot. I mean,
you're probably not doing that right now, but uh,
definitely useful when you do have 18,005 star reviews.
So it's really hard to go wrong. The attention to detail is great.
The price for what you get is great. The feeling on the wrist is great.
Like I say,
the best thing is that they're not forgettable like a lot of minimalist watches
and they just look plus,
so please do go check out the full range and take advantage of their sixth sale.
Getting 30% off,
site-wide go to Inserra watches.com forward slash biographics.
Then there's no need to use a code on checkout.
30% off will be automatic and let's get back to it.
[Inaudible].
The last known person to see Elizabeth shorter life was a 25 year old salesman
named Robert Redman. Lee, who was dating her at the time.
The two had returned from a trip to San Diego on the 8th of January and Manley
dropped her off in front of the Biltmore hotel in Hollywood, the following day,
unsurprisingly,
he was the police's first suspect and was picked up for questioning a few days
after Short's body was found.
Manley had previously been discharged from the army and had been described as
being mentally unstable after suffering multiple nervous breakdowns.
Fortunately for him, he had a solid alibi for the time of the murder.
Plus he also agreed to take a lie detector test on two separate occasions and
passed both of them. Red manly was in the clear,
but the real killer was seemingly none too pleased that somebody else was
getting the attention that he deserved a few days after the murder,
a man proporting to be the killer called the office of the Los Angeles examiner
speaking with the editor,
he expressed his disappointment as to how the case was being presented.
He also claims that he intended to turn himself in eventually,
but wanted to let the police pursue him a bit further. Lastly, the call,
a promise to confirm that he was indeed the real killer by sending some of
Elizabeth Short's belongings.
Clearly he was confident that unless he revealed his identity,
that was no way for the authorities to discover who he was the next day.
An envelope arrived at the newspaper, which contained shorts, birth certificate,
business cards, photographs,
and an address book with the name Mark Hanson written on the cover.
Hansen was a nightclub owner who occasionally allowed Elizabeth to sleep at his
house because she was a close friend of his girlfriends.
He was also one of the last people to speak to short and became a suspect early
in the investigation that same day, the victim's handbag.
And it's one of our shoes were found on top of a trashcan,
a couple of miles from where a body was discovered.
There were no identifying items in the past,
but red manly recognized it as belonging to short for a moment,
it seemed like a pretty big mistake from an otherwise thorough and careful
killer. And police got their hopes up that they could find some fingerprints,
alas. They were not so fortunate. The murderer had been a bit callous,
but not enough,
even though he probably never expected the handbag to be identified.
He still had the forethought to wipe it down with gasoline.
Same thing went for the package that he sent to the examiner.
Speaking of which that sent down to be the first of many communications that the
killer,
or at least someone claiming to be the killer has with the media and the police.
More and more letters started arriving at the offices of the Los Angeles
newspapers covering the blank daily app.
Most of them were pieced together for magazines and newspaper clippings.
I will give up daily a killing. If I get 10 years, don't try to find me.
He never followed up on that offer. So it's unclear if he meant it genuinely,
or if it was just another way to talk.
The police lab tests revealed that these letters all use the same kind of paper
and envelopes as the original package that included Elizabeth Short's
belongings.
So it is generally considered that they came from the killer that seemed changed
as numerous anonymous tips and confessions started pouring in.
Most of them proven to be hoaxes.
Things only got worse off one of the Los Angeles city.
Councilman offered a $10,000 reward for any information on the black daily
killer.
Please tap to sift through 500 tips coming in from people described as an array
of Housewives soldiers, whiners farmers, and clergymen, even decades later,
the LAPD has said that they still receive around half a dozen confessions every
year.
At least some people were a bit more creative with their false confessions.
About a month after the murder police found the scene of an apparent suicide,
a of clothes were found on the beach and inside one of the shoes was a note
which read.
I have waited for the police to capture me for the black daily killing,
but have not. I am too much of a coward to turn myself in.
So this is the best way out for me.
The note was not signed and it's nobody washed ashore that could have
potentially been the office.
Authorities have dismissed this as another grim hoax.
The problem was that despite thousands of man hours, dozens of investigators,
and even FBI assistants,
the LAPD made little headway other than these hoaxes and false confessions,
pretty early in the investigation.
Police became convinced that the killer had some sort of medical training.
So they enlisted the FBI to look at medical and dental students in Southern
California for possible suspects.
This yielded dozens of leads that none good enough for an arrest.
There was also the master of an actual witness. You probably saw the killer.
A man who lived in the area came forward saying that he drove by the empty lot
where Elisabeth's body was found on the night of the murder.
He wanted to throw away some garden clippings, but as he approached the lot,
he saw another man there at around 9:00 PM.
The witness describes the possible killer is middle-aged thin medium height
wearing a tan coat into dark, half driving, a light colored, 1935 sedan.
The neighbor left in his car,
but went once around the block and drove past the lots. Again,
his second arrival startled the other man enough that he went inside his own car
and sped off. Good. This have actually been the black Dahlia killer.
Is it possible that the neighbor interrupted him before he had finished
everything he intended to do to Elizabeth Short?
Unfortunately like most aspects of this case,
these questions can only be answered with speculate.
Two months into the investigation.
The LAPD had around 75 suspects who they considered good enough to screech and
ice. By the time they went to a grand jury, a couple of years later,
they had close to 200 and he gets the only arrests ever made in this case with
obstruction of justice pertaining to false confessions.
As most of you probably already knew when you started watching this video,
the killer of the black Dahlia has never been identified,
but quite a few noteworthy suspects have been put forward.
We already talked about Redman Lee,
but we didn't go into detail regarding Mark Hanson.
The man whose address book was sent to the newspaper along with shorts,
belongings, he was, and actually it still remains a chief suspect,
not necessarily because of his address books,
since he gave that as a gift to Elizabeth Short,
but because he gave contradictory statements while being investigated by
detectives,
further inquiries revealed that Hanson and trying to seduce short while she was
staying at his home, but that she rebuffed his advances.
He was never charged with anything bus.
There were rumors that Hanson used as wealth and connections to law enforcement
to extricate himself from the investigation. So let's move on to Leslie Dillon,
a 27 year old bellhop who inserted himself into the investigation by writing to
discuss the case with LAPD psychiatrist, Dr. Jay pulled a river.
He also used to work as a mortician's assistant.
So he knew how to handle a corpse penis and drain it of blood.
Dylan first wrote to Dr. De river,
asking for info on the case claiming he had an interest in sadists and
psychopaths for a book that he intended to write.
He then expressed his belief that a friend of his name's Jeff Connors was the
man who killed Elizabeth Short during his correspondence.
Dylan showed intimate knowledge of the murder.
And eventually the psychiatrist became convinced that the bellhop was the real
killer and that Jeff Connors was in fact,
a violent extension of his own personality. The LAPD brought Dylan into custody,
but were later surprised when San Francisco police called them.
So let them know that they found Jeff Connors. He was indeed real.
And he worked in Los Angeles at the time of the murder as a handyman for
Columbia studios. However, other than Dylan's opinion,
that was nothing to connect him to the crime.
As far as the bellhop was concerned,
police were eventually forced to move on after finding evidence to suggest that
Dylan May have been in San Francisco at the time of the murder,
but this was never proven conclusively for a while.
Leslie Dillon was the police's main suspect. And even in modern times,
multiple crime buffs writers and former detectives still consider him the black
Dahlia killer. While looking at hundreds of suspects,
police never really lost sight of the medical connection.
They were fairly certain that Elizabeth Short's color had to be someone with
basic medical knowledge to do things that he did to our body.
Whenever a doctor appeared in that cross, as they always paid closer attention,
once such suspect was Patrick.
O'Reilly a doctor who met Sean through Mark Hanson at his nightclub out of
everyone who Riley clearly had the most disturbing violent streak.
As he had previously been convicted for assault with a deadly weapon for taking
his secretary to a motel where he beaten,
tortured her almost to the point of death.
It seems like he had these sadistic proclivities and the medical know-how to
commit to the black Dahlia murder. But the case against him remains an unproven.
One, one small as it usually happens in these cases,
investigators sent to consider the idea that this may not have been the killers
FastMed up, looking back at similar crimes,
one potential candidate jumped out at them. The Cleveland torso matter,
also known as the mad butcher of Kingsbury run this serial killer murdered and
dismembered, at least a dozen people in the late 1930s,
his viciousness equals even surpassed that of the blank daily killer.
So it was natural to consider that they may be the same person even.
So there was never any evidence to connect to the cases other than the violence
of some of the murders. Some of the more Outlander suspects include gangsta,
Bugsy, Siegel, and.
AXA Rolson Wells. Many of the people.
Who worked at the case always felt deep down in that palms of hearts that they
knew who the killer was, even though they couldn't prove it.
Ralph hostel was the last living detective from the original investigation.
When he died in 2003,
he remained convinced that a man he tracked down and interviewed based on the
testimony you have, the only eyewitness was in fact,
the killer Aggie Underwood's pioneering Los Angeles crime reporter.
And according to her,
the first journalist to arrive at the scene of the black Dalian murder also
believed that she knew the identity of the man who killed Elizabeth Short.
But when pressed for an answer,
she only said that he's dead and it doesn't matter anymore.
So we ended the story with a look at the man who is currently at the top of the
suspect list for many people, George huddle.
He came to the attention of the police in 1949 when he was charged,
but acquitted of sexually assaulting his own daughter. It was a doctor.
So we had the medical knowledge.
He was suspected of involvement in the death of his secretary from a drug
overdose. And he was also interviewed in 1949 in a different killing,
known as the green twig murder. At one point, the police even bugged his home,
but couldn't obtain incriminating evidence. Huddle died in 1999,
but he came back into the spotlight as a prominent suspect courtesy of his son,
Steve huddle is a retired LAPD detective who was become convinced that his
father killed Elizabeth Short all those years ago,
going through his father's belongings,
he found evidence such as personal photographs of a young woman.
He believes to be the aspiring actress as well as letters from his father whose
handwriting matches the letters from the killer sent to newspapers decades ago.
Steve Hodel has spent the last two decades trying to convince others that George
huddle was the man who killed Elizabeth Short.
The black Dahlia.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos a few times a week on this
channel. And as always thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].